you're familiar with
death by powerpoint can you raise your
hands
and death by excel
right and tableau
right so i'm going to talk about data
visualization and how you can use it
to think more and to
convince more people
but first i want to play a game can you
guess the missing word
anybody it's
data if you want to convince
people you need data yes the problem is
that
data usually looks like this
and it will leave people feeling like
these and if you want to convince them
you know you need to make them excited
right hence
data visualization the second problem is
that there is a lot of
bad bad data visualization i'm going to
show you some examples from the internet
this is a chart representing the 100
most
active accounts wrong chart for the job
this is another chart number of data
scientists
per country information overload
and my favorite the useless chart
so i am a professor and as an academic
i went on a quest to find out why
we have so much bad visualization
and i found out the culprit
school dropout never took a design
course yet his software
is used to produce 90 of the charts that
you will see
in your life
that he is not the only at fault here as
the education system we also have blame
on this
because to do data visualization you
need data skills
but you also need design skills but the
data guys they look like
this and the designers look like this
and they
don't go to the same schools and the
schools where they teach data
they don't have design and vice versa
there's very very few schools where they
teach both
well
so to fix this i'm going to give you six
rules
be awesome at data visualization number
one tell me a story when you make a
chart
tell me a story because
if you say something some people will
remember if you make a chart
more people will remember it if you make
a story out of it it's even better
number two know the difference between
data and information what is the
difference
second exercise can you order these four
keywords
give you five seconds
first information then data then
knowledge and wisdom okay
when i give this to my students most of
them come up with this arrangement
so what what makes them arrange words
like this what's the difference what's
the attributes of data versus wisdom
so data is abundant there is a lot of
data wisdom is
it's a scarce and it's valuable
right and this row is called the arrow
of
value
number three know how to create
knowledge what is knowledge
this pyramid is called the data
information
knowledge wisdom model
and how do you transform data into
information
well one way is to summarize to reduce
overload
how do you transform information into
knowledge
right so one way is to get your
new information that you found and put
it
in context to relate it to other
bodies of existing knowledge
that's how einstein got his nobel prize
and what is wisdom
yes
right so one guy told me jose
if you want to be a leader it's not only
what you say
it's when you say it that's wisdom
and there's two thinking modes here
you need an exploratory thinking mode
what in design thinking we call
diversion thinking and then you need a
different thinking mode
conversion thinking number four
if you make a chart and nobody likes it
on
twitter did it really happen
no let's say you have this chart
how do you make it more memorable use
pop culture for example personas
number five understand how to use
narratives
in a chart or in a presentation
what is the relationship what is the
role between
these three elements well
the role of data is to lend credibility
to your story
what's the role of the story to advance
the narrative and what is the narrative
in this tale
that we want to teach our kids not to
trust
strangers but you cannot go to a
five-year-old and tell him that
you need to wrap it in a story
it works also for adults
can you identify the narrative the story
and the data here
350 million is the data this is the
story that we send money out
and the narrative is let's take control
fake numbers but very effective
number six choose a chart that is
compatible with what you want to
say for example
this is data gender breakdown of data
scientist worldwide
if i ask people to visualize this most
people come up with this chart
histogram some of the people come up
with each
a pie chart oh let's come up with this
one r chart
what is the problem with the pie chart
here what is a pie it's a metaphor
for a cake what happens when you have 50
kids
around a cake there's going to be a
fight it's the scarcity narrative
so you have to be careful if your chart
is compatible
with what you want to say a more neutral
chart
is the stack bar
but it's kind of boring how would you
make it more interesting memorable
well we can use personas in the case we
chose
superheroes and remember
if they don't remember it it didn't
happen so whenever you can dramatize
so i'm going to show you two examples of
very very improvable
presentations two years ago elon musk
was talking about
solar panels he wanted to promote solar
panels
he said we just need to cover
one pixel of the usa to fulfill
our energy needs
well this presentation was a flop
why well can you trust something that
you don't see
and second what is the narrative here
which piece of land are we gonna use for
this it's gonna be your land or your
land
same purpose different strategy
a few years earlier a german company
called q cells use a similar chart like
this one
it's a different narrative
look at how much solar energy hits the
earth in one year
it's so many let's use some of some of
it
so very same purpose different charts
different outcome another one
this is co2 emission concentration
and this is temperature and this is al
gore
and this is a lift they put algorithm a
leaf
to show that the concentrations are of
the charts
this presentation got 62 000 views on
youtube
purely few years later professor from
the uk
ed hawkings takes less data
and creates this chart spiral chart
he posts it on twitter it went viral
in minutes
temperatures spiraling out of control
but then comes my favorite person
ignores all these charts and tells us a
story
and what's the story here hey i have to
go to this climate
conference but i'm not going to chat
because
i have integrity and i want to reduce my
carbon footprint and what's the data
here
look at these big waves behind me they
look so
menacing this is dangerous this is an
emergency
so same data three different ways to
tell the story
three different outcomes so summarizing
if you want to be awesome at data
visualization
first tell me a story second data is not
information
third know how to create knowledge
four make it memorable
five use narratives and six
choose a chart that is compatible thank
you very much